A salsa bar in a Taco Time, in Dalles Oregon
is the site of the largest bio-terrorist attack in US history
and no this is not a joke
In 1970 in India a spiritual leader named Bhagwan Shree Rajneesh began a new movement
the philosophy of the Rajneeshee movement was an odd mix of capitalism, meditation
and dirty and ethnic jokes
Nonetheless he managed to accumulate a large following
By the 1980s his movement had swelled to the tens of thousands
Rajneesh wanted to start his utopia
so with the help of this woman Ma Anand Sheela
they purchased 64,000 acres, a ranch in Oregon
and it was here that they began building their utopia
Some seven thousand followers moved onto this ranch property
the followers all wore red, they adhered to very strict schedules
meanwhile Ma Anand Sheela began calling herself Queen and carrying around a 357 Magnum
the Rajneeshees also began driving around town in a jeep
with a machine gun on the back of it
the plan was to overwhelm these towns by basically taking over their political systems
the Rajneeshees had already taken over a nearby town called Antelope
and renamed the town Rajneesh
so the huge influx of these red clad cultists
didn’t sit that well with the local conservative small towners in Oregon
the Rajneeshee movement needed ways to inflate their numbers
and essentially keep the locals away from the voting polls
what if everyone was too sick to actually go out and vote
In September of 1984 a woman stood at the Salsa Bar in Taco Time
holding a small bag of her own “homemade salsa”
she poured it across all of the condiments
and this started what was the largest bio-terrorist attack in US history
the group contaminated ten different fast food restaurants
with Salmonella over the course of two months
It made 757 people sick, it sent a couple dozen people to the hospital
had they gone with their initial plan of using typhoid fever
it would have been a massacre
when this finally was discovered it was found
that they had set up a fully fledged bio-terrorism lab on the compound
Ma Anand Sheela and her co-conspirator were given twenty years in prison
but ultimately only ended up serving two
And Rajneesh actually didn't serve a day in jail
the attack on the salsa bar at the Taco Time and nine other fast food restaurants
remains the largest bio-terrorist attack in US history
amazingly, that Taco Time is still open
we suggest you skip the Salsa Bar
Subscribe here and watch more videos here
Today there is still a plaque in the town of Antelope
It’s awesome it’s at the post office
And its like something out of a movie
like “To all those who stood against the Rajneeshee invasion"
What are some other wonders that I should know about?
What do you want to hear me talk about, what do you want to tell me about
what is the greatest place you have ever been?
I want to know all of these things